hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 10 y hablaremos de la
luz y la materia nosotros estamos hechos
de materia y he puesto materia en la
pantalla pero no la pueden ver porque no
hay luz pero con luz podemos ver materia
sólida líquida gaseosa o plasma entonces
necesitamos de la luz para poder
investigar a la materia por eso en este
vídeo hablaremos de la luz y de la
materia
recuerden que la luz viaja en algo
llamado fotones y podemos cuantificar la
luz usando la ley de plank en donde la
energía es igual a h por no h es la
constante de planck y no es la
frecuencia pero podemos usar los fotones
para estudiar la materia porque si
tenemos una molécula y absorbe un fotón
es decir absorbe una cierta cantidad de
energía cuando se libera el fotón
también se libera algo de esa energía
así que podemos usar diferentes tipos de
fotones para conocer diferentes
es cosas sobre las moléculas por ejemplo
la luz infrarroja es muy importante
cuando analizamos las vibraciones de
átomos y moléculas para saber qué tipo
de enlaces tienen pero si usamos luz
ultravioleta o luz visible podemos
analizar la configuración electrónica
para conocer en dónde se encuentran los
electrones externos y qué hacen y
finalmente también podemos analizar
soluciones usando luz si hacemos incidir
luz a través de una solución un poco de
esa luz será absorbida y de acuerdo a la
ley de bir lambert podemos conocer cuál
es la concentración de las moléculas que
absorbieron esa luz entonces la luz es
una onda y a la vez es una partícula si
la vemos como una onda aquí tenemos el
espectro electromagnético que va desde
las ondas de radio hasta los rayos gamma
las ondas de radio tienen una longitud
de onda alta y una frecuencia baja ese
es el número de ondas que tenemos por
segundo
mientras que los rayos gamma tienen una
frecuencia alta y una longitud de onda
baja y bueno nosotros sólo podemos
percibir una pequeña parte de todo esto
cuando observamos algo únicamente
podemos percibir la luz visible entonces
la luz es una onda pero también es una
partícula eso significa que se puede
cuantificar y podemos verlo así pondré
un poco de música de fondo
este es rahman y no para violín y piano
por ejemplo un violín puede tocar
cualquier nota y simplemente tenemos que
mover nuestro dedo pero en el piano es
más específico solo podemos tocar todo o
re o mí así que en realidad la luz es
como un piano en la que tenemos pequeñas
cantidades de fotones de una cierta
energía y podemos medir esa energía
usando la ley de plank que es igual a h
por no la constante de planck por la
frecuencia de la luz entonces cuál de
estas longitudes de onda
la mayor cantidad de energía claro la
que tiene la frecuencia más alta por lo
tanto son los rayos gamma mientras que
las ondas de radio tienen menor energía
entonces analizar la absorción de los
fotones nos puede decir mucho sobre lo
que están haciendo los electrones en
esos átomos y para eso nos sirve un
espectroscopio que nos ayuda a ver todo
el espectro electromagnético uno de los
primeros científicos que hizo esto fue
newton si quieren construir uno todo lo
que necesitan es un prisma y unas
rejillas pequeñas por las que pase la
luz aquí podemos ver los diferentes
colores de la luz y en una clase de
química pueden construir un
espectroscopio barato como este aquí
tiene una abertura y del otro lado tiene
unas rejillas de difracción entonces si
observamos la luz veremos algo como esto
pero si tenemos luz incandescente se
verá un poco diferente y bueno un
espectrómetro es simplemente un
espectroscopio más sofisticado
de un lado tenemos la fuente luz después
tenemos las rejillas y ahora el detector
es una cámara digital que percibe más
luz de la que nosotros podemos ver y
finalmente colocamos nuestra muestra
entonces los diferentes espectrómetros
nos ayudan a ver diferentes cosas por
ejemplo la espectroscopia r nos ayuda a
analizar la luz infrarroja y es muy
interesante porque hay una vibración
entre los átomos pero también entre las
moléculas por ejemplo aquí tenemos un
carbono y dos hidrógenos hay mucha
vibración en esta molécula y si hacemos
irradiar luz infrarroja los enlaces
pueden absorber un poco de esa energía y
eso hará que vibren aún más es como
empujar a alguien en un columpio si lo
empujen con la misma fuerza en algún
momento empezará a elevarse más y más
entonces lo que sucede es que la luz
infrarroja es absorbida y bueno usando
un espectrómetro y erc podemos saber qué
frecuencias de la luz son absorbidas y
después podemos usar una correlación
como esta que nos dirá qué tipo de
enlaces encontraremos en esa molécula
ahora si queremos saber más pero sobre
la configuración electrónica podemos
usar la luz sube o visible se usa el
mismo tipo de espectroscopia tenemos luz
y tenemos el detector pero esta vez
usamos luz v o luz visible y ahora en
vez de aumentar la vibración de las
moléculas queremos saber cuáles son los
electrones que brincan a un nivel más
alto de energía así que podemos usar un
espectro como este que nos dirá más
sobre qué están haciendo los electrones
de valencia y finalmente tenemos la ley
de bir lambert aquí tenemos un ejemplo
en el que estamos haciendo incidir un
láser verde en esta solución y podemos
ver que el láser no logra traspasar todo
y eso es porque seguramente hay
moléculas que están absorbiendo una
parte de esa luz
miren esta es una simulación de ph et de
este lado tenemos una luz entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es medir la cantidad
de luz que pasa a través de esto
prendemos la luz y queremos saber la
absorban cya para saber qué tanta luz
pasa a través de esta solución en este
caso es una solución de cloruro de
cobalto y miren si la concentración es
baja pasa más luz pero al aumentar la
concentración logra pasar menos luz esta
es la ley de bird lambert conforme
aumentamos la concentración menos luz
pasa a través de la solución y podemos
hacer un pequeño experimento supongamos
que tenemos una concentración de 0 luego
de 50 y luego de 100 observen lo que
sucede con la absorban cya conforme
incrementamos la concentración ahora a
150 más luz es absorbida y ahora
aumentamos a 250 bueno aquí están los
datos
izquierdo tenemos la concentración y del
lado derecho la absorban cya y a simple
vista parece que existe una relación
lineal y si lo grafica mos si así es
entonces encontramos que conforme
aumentamos la concentración de la
solución más luz es absorbida así que
ahora podríamos tomar una muestra medir
su absorban cya y podremos conocer cuál
es la concentración de esa solución
entonces que aprendimos bueno aprendimos
que la luz usando la ley de plank viaja
en forma de fotones que podemos
cuantificar y podemos usar eso para
investigar a la materia porque las
moléculas pueden absorber o dejar ir a
esos fotones y después recuerden los
tres análisis principales la luz
infrarroja nos permite analizar la
vibración de las moléculas y nos da
información sobre sus enlaces la luz
ultravioleta y visible nos da
información sobre la configuración
electrónica y en donde se encuentran los
electrones
y si analizamos soluciones cómo pueden
absorber una parte de la luz
podemos usar la ley de bird lambert para
conocer la concentración de una solución
tomando como referencia la absorban cya
espero que hayan aprendido a elegir la
espectroscopia adecuada para medir la
vibración o el movimiento electrónico de
las moléculas recuerden si buscamos
analizar la vibración necesitamos
espectroscopia infrarroja pero si
queremos saber más sobre la
configuración electrónica entonces
necesitamos espectroscopia v visible y
finalmente podemos usar la absorción de
la luz para determinar la concentración
de una solución que contiene moléculas
absorbentes esa es la ley de bir lambert
conforme aumentamos la concentración
aumenta la absorban cya espero que les
sirva